>> Well, thank you Tuomas
for being here today.
It's great to see you.
>> My pleasure to be here again.
>> It's great to
have you come in and
share your thoughts with us
at the Microsoft Research AI
distinguished lecture series.
We've known each other
for a very long time.
I remember when I think when
you were a grad student
asking me all these
questions that
informs at the
international meeting
of Operations Research
and Management Science.
I turned around and said, "
Who's this really smart guy
asking me all these questions?"
I first met Tuomas that
way and what I really was
excited about was
it seemed we shared
interests in operations research,
decision analysis, AI, the span,
the arc of concepts
to all those fields,
which only more recently
have come together,
for the current viewpoint
and perspective on
machine intelligence.
So, that was [inaudible].
How did you get going
in this whole area
because I knew you
had a history in
Nokia being in Finland
and working as
a young student in
areas around probability
and statistics?
How did you get into this field?
>> Yeah, I actually
started studying
management science and
industrial engineering,
and then just operations
research and systems analysis,
and AI really just drew me
in as a undergrad really.
Then, for a master's thesis,
I built the Traconet,
which is the first
distributed system
for negotiation among
self interested agents.
That really spawned
more questions than answers
so I decided to come to
the US to do my PhD in that,
and it's always been kind
of interdisciplinary
between computer science
and in AI in particular,
and operations research,
and economics,
in particular game theory.
>> Yeah, so go back to
that project thing and
what was it called again and?
>> Traconet or Transportation
Corporation Net.
>> What was it all about?
>> It was this thing
where I got to
really shape it myself as
a master's thesis student.
They have sold this project.
>> This is in Finland?
>> In Finland at the Technical
Research Center of Finland,
and they have sold
this project before I
joined to some companies that
has some trucking needs.
Some of them were
transporting heavy goods like
construction things and others
were transporting
very light things, and so on.
Then, they realized that they had
some potential for cooperation,
reallocating tasks among
themselves, and so on.
From there I could just
take it in any
direction I wanted,
and I wanted to build
an automated negotiations.
>> But how did you yourself
get pulled into this?
>> Well, I had like
three different options
to look at my master's thesis
and I liked that as
the most open ended novel.
>> With these practical projects,
you have to engage
in it at times?
>> Yeah. There's
a master's thesis
or master's research thesis.
Yeah, and there
were many different
options and I like three of them,
and this I liked the best.
>> So, what got you excited about
the self interested
distributed aspects of things.
>> Well, I had been studying
game theory and optimization,
and I felt that a lot
of the stuff hadn't
been put together.
So, there's a lot of good work.
I needed to programming
and things like that,
and a lot of good
work on game theory.
People hadn't really put
those two things together.
>> Did this trucking
system work out?
>> Yeah. So, it was
just a prototype system so we
collected real data and
showed how it would
work on real data,
but it wasn't ever, we
didn't actually field
it or anything.
That wasn't even the goal. It
was really just a prototype
and then I left to
the US to do my PhD.
>> Okay. Now, before we get
into the PhD work and beyond,
let's take a brief break
and talk about your
windsurfing career.
So, how did that get
going and how did you
become the Finland champion
in windsurfing?
>> Yeah. So, I've
been racing sailor boats
since I was a little kid.
Then, you can really sail
optimist thing until
you're 15 but I
got too big and heavy so
the boat wouldn't just go.
So, I needed a different class
and windsurfing had just
become so hot and athletic,
and it could actually take
a little bit of a bigger guy.
So, I started windsurfing and
then in a couple of years,
some of the coaches in
Finland saw me and how
I did in the races,
and they picked me
onto the national team
for four and a half years.
So, throughout high school
and throughout the air force,
I was actually sailing around
in the world championships.
So, when I'm windsurfing
and in the winters,
we would go down south to
practice when Finland was
all covered with ice.
>> Down south where?
>> Canary Islands.
Sometimes, Spain.
>> Where does
a Finnish person go to
practice windsurfing
in the summer?
>> Yeah.
>> It's interesting. Yeah, I was
impressed that you
mention this in
the past and I even
see in your formal CV.
>> Yes.
>> I see '86 of
this as we're going
Finland windsurfing champ
for the year.
>> Yes, and my best race
was actually being the
fifth in the Europeans.
I was also 12th in the world.
But really, the best races
were in the Europeans.
>> Before we get off that do
you still do windsurfing?
>> Yeah.
>> Even though it's
not hot any more.
>> No, it's actually
really nice that it's
not hot anymore.
You have a lot more
space to do it.
I thought you'd be on
paddle-boards by this time.
>> No, no. So, I'm
loyal to what I do.
>> Yeah, and never ice hockey.
>> I played ice hockey as a kid.
>> Okay. Just sometime-
>> Being a Finnish kid,
you don't have to.
>> Just checking in on this.
>> Yes, I know you play.
>> So, then you went
off to Amherst.
>> Yeah.
>> How was that experience?
What kind of things
to work on there?
>> Great. I had read
a lot of papers in
multi-agent systems already doing
this transportation corporation
net system in Finland,
and I looked at who's
publishing most in
multi-agent system,
and I sent Victor
lesser email and he accepted
me as a grad student.
We actually flew there to
meet before we committed.
So, we interviewed each
other a little bit,
and then we decided to work
together and it was great.
>> I always found Victor
with many years as a very,
very kind, thoughtful,
caring man.
>> That's right. We still talk
about stuff and he's
still my mentor.
>> That's fabulous. I'm
sure that he probably,
some of his personality,
his mentorship abilities have
rubbed off on you over the years.
>> Yeah, I try.
>> So, you finished that up
and then what was next
for you, your PhD?
>> Yeah. So, then I went to be
assistant professor at
Washington University,
St. Louis, where I started
my own research group.
Then, four years later,
CMU hired me out of there.
>> So, at CMU, you've
been this force
in combinatorial auctions and
some interesting results
you've proved them,
and you and your students have
proved in that space
over the years.
You've not only done
this great scholarship,
you've been spinning out
companies like CombineNet.
I think you were running
CombineNet for many years.
It must have been
at least a decade.
>> Yes.
>> So, what was that all about?
The CombineNet experience?
>> Yes, CombineNet, I started
building the technology in '97,
and then I founded the company
in 2000. You're right.
I mean, we were continuing until
2010 before it was acquired,
and we fielded 800 of
the world's still largest scale
combinatorial auctions
ever fielded,
totaling $60 billion
and we created
a supply chain efficiency
of over $6 billion.
>> So, then of
course, they gave you
most of that money, right?
>> Sourcing software
is the worst business,
I can tell that, in
terms of raw margins.
>> Well, hopefully a little
piece of it at some point.
>> Yeah, you have to
basically sell software
to the toughest
negotiators in the world.
That's what they do all day long.
They push their suppliers down on
pricing so they do the same
to the software vendors.
>> So, what was
your experience like with
the whole startup world?
>> Yeah, it was very interesting.
A lot of people think
that the interaction
between academia
and startup is like
you just license
technology from academia,
and it's a one way, but
this was really both ways.
Actually, more so the other way,
where we actually saw
problems in the real world,
that hadn't been
looked at in academia.
Many of those things, we actually
brought back to my academic lab,
and then we were the first ones
to look at these things,
like, preference elicitation
in multi-agent systems,
automated mechanism design,
structured domain
specific building languages
for combinatorial auctions etc.
>> So, when did
you start getting involved
in code from that realm?
I see the relationships
but some people in
the outside world might
not see them to the world,
the realm of kidney exchanges.
How did you get exposed to that?
Maybe you can explain to folks,
some of the things with
the big grand challenge of
kidney exchanges is and
why it's a hard problem,
and why it's so
valuable to solve,
and then how you get
interested in that?
Well, it is a multi-part
question there.
>> Okay great. So, how
I got interested in
kidney exchanges-
>> What is it first of all?
What is this? Because people
don't have any understanding
at all about this.
>> Okay. So,
kidney exchange is there
to help alleviate the problem
if there aren't
enough organ donors,
who donate organs when they die.
So, there's this big imbalance
of supply and demand.
Not just in the US,
but in most countries.
So, for example, in the US,
there are over 100,000
people that are listed to
wait for dead people's kidneys,
and these are people
who are very sick,
and are eventually going to
die if they don't get them.
So, you can do live
donation because most people
have two kidneys.
Like if you get sick,
I can give you one of my kidneys.
I offered to give you one.
But chances are, I
can't due to blood type
and tissue type incompatibility
and few other factors.
So, that's where
kidney exchange comes in.
So, you actually,
at the simplest,
to swap the donors.
So, if we were a willing pair,
donor patient pair,
some other pair is willing
but also incompatible.
>> It could be
anywhere in the world?
>> Well, currently, they're
just willing countries,
but many countries have them.
But so think about in the US,
California and Massachusetts say.
So, I am going to
donate to somebody
else and their donor is
going to donate to you.
Now both of the
patients can live.
If you think about that from
a graph perspective,
that is a two cycle.
You can also do three cycles
and you can do what we
call never ending
arteries donor initiated chains.
So, somebody actually
gives a kidney,
does not expect
anything in return.
Instead of a cycle,
that triggers a chain
in the network,
and at the end of the chain
there is last willing donor,
which can serve as
this outreach in
the next week's
optimization patch
and it is a gift
that keeps giving.
But the hard optimization
problem in the batch setting is
figuring out
the optimal combination
of cycles and shapes.
>> Okay, so that
is the challenge.
How on earth did you first get
exposed to this and
get excited about it?
>> So, I was on the
organizational committee of
the International Congress of the
Game Theory Society in 2004,
and as one of our invited
speakers we invited Al Roffe,
who had just started
working with some
medical collaborators
and some other economists
on the New England
Paired Kidney Exchange.
He spoke about kidney exchange,
so that is how I
first heard about it
and I saw that there were
a lot of computer science,
the ORS' problems in
there and I thought
that that would be a nice way
to do some pro bono work.
>> And to give back.
Yeah, exactly.
So this is not a start up.
We run the nationwide
kidney exchange for UNOS,
so we donate the software
for my [inaudible]
>> What is UNOS?
>> UNOS Is the United Network
for Organ Sharing.
They control the transplant
patients in the US,
both from the deceased
donor side and
kidney exchange side at
least for the National
Kidney Exchange,
and our software runs
the kidney exchange side of it.
So every week it makes
a transplant plan
for 69% of the
transplant centers.
>> That is amazing.
>> In the US. This year
we are we giving away the
software. It is not a startup.
>> Well, first of all
before I even get to how it
works and how you
monitor it and so on,
what hard core problems
even if they are just
applications and transfer of
existing ideas did you have
to work with to solve
the kidney exchange challenge?
>> So, one was just this
optimization problem
and the batch
optimization problem.
But then as we got more into it,
we realized that that
is not the only thing.
There are a lot of things
that go around it.
So, for example the problem
is dynamic; patients die,
they get deceased donor organs,
other kidney exchanges
may snipe them,
other things might happen,
they get sick, they
cannot be transplanted.
So, the problem is dynamic and
also new pairs come
to the exchange,
new outreach come to
the exchange and so on.
Another issue is that
there are what I call
pre-transplant failures.
So, the medical
knowledge is incomplete.
If it says that we
are compatible,
in reality we may or may not be.
It turns out that
most kidney exchange structures,
cycles of chains worldwide
actually fail before
transplant because if
even one of those edges
turns out to be actually not
compatible or one of
the patients dies or gets
a deceased donor organ,
something happens between
the planning stage
and the operation,
which is about eight
weeks typically,
the whole structure fails,
90% of the structures fail.
So, how can we actually do
this failure aware planning.
We just had a paper out in
management science on
that and you can get
much better numbers
of transplants
by not just looking at how
good an edge would be,
how good it would be,
but how likely it is
to succeed as well.
So, now you are taking
extra information into
account and you are making
these more robust plans.
>> What is it likely
to come from?
>> The likelihood.
>> Of succeeding, I mean.
>> The likelihood of
succeeding could come from
machine learning models,
but even if you
just say that it is
the same average probability
across everybody,
you get still 100-150% lift
in transplant.
So, even if you do not take
into account the fact that
some ages are more likely
to fail than others.
And what this looks like then in
practice you have shorter cycles,
you have shorter chains and
more parallelism in the plans.
So then those structures are less
likely to fail because
they have fewer edges,
and if they do fail it
affects fewer transplants.
>> I see.
Is it the case that the patient
and nephrologist
and team and family
will ever have to do
this idea of a trade,
like, my kidney function
is crashing at this rate or
I can't do more dialysis.
It's hard to wait longer
but this match is not
great to wait for
the next match and
have a probability distribution
over the problem of
getting a better match
within that time horizon?
>> Yes. Some people
have looked at
that as a decision as to
how long should you wait.
We haven't really studied that so
much and it is my understanding
that patients really are not
presented a menu of kidneys
or anything like that.
It is more like when
a matching kidneys found,
people are very happy with it.
Now, I will tell you a little bit
of a counterexample
to what I just said.
We were working with the
Alliance for Paired Donation.
This was in 2006-2007.
It is a private kidney
exchange and there,
there was this, I want to say
60-year-old uncle and
a 13-year-old kid,
this 13-year-old-girl, and it is
clear that that
60-year-old kidney would
not last adequately long in
that little kid because
the little kid still had
a lot of life ahead of her.
>> This thing is to look
at the actual amount
of trade you have
on the RP receive
into a patient whose tread
is there for the future.
>> So they were actually
compatible already without
the kidney exchange,
but they came to
the kidney exchange and said
that you have three months,
if you can find
a better match for the girl,
the uncle is going to
give to somebody else,
and we actually
algorithmically found
a better match just in
the normal process.
So, now we took
this compatible pair,
put them into
the kidney exchange,
and for somebody who was older,
that uncle's kidney was great.
Then, the girl got
a younger kidney.
>> I hadn't really
thought about in
organ transplants that you
have the age of the tissue itself
and has piece of little, where.
Will these cells live as long as
this patient perform over
the time when they have
their own lifespan as part
of the donor's life history?
>> Yes.
>> Very interesting.
So, moving on from
the medical successes
into other areas.
So, you see your team
is renowned for beating
the best players at
heads of no limit
Texas Hold'em poker.
This is remarkable in
some ways in that it goes
beyond what we often refer to as
the simplicity frankly of
games of perfect information.
We could explain the difference
going from checkers or
Go into the realm of
uncertainty bluffing-
>> Yeah.
>> -human dimension.
>> Yeah. So, imperfect
information games like let's
say tic tac toe,
checkers, chess, Go.
You know exactly what
the state of the world
is when it's your turn to move.
Then, you can use techniques
like Minimax search,
Alpha-beta pruning,
and end-game databases
that all stuff.
>> You can build
huge databases by just
playing oneself
a trillion times as well.
>> Yes. There have
been great successes.
Some of those games are
very difficult as well.
Like chess is still unsolved,
Go still unsolved, but they
have reached superhuman level
at that and it's very impressive.
In imperfect information game,
the situation is
totally different.
None of those
algorithms is applied.
In imperfect information games,
you don't know the state of
the world when it's
your turn to act.
To complicate things,
your opponents may know things
that you don't know
and vice versa.
So, you have to
think about what do
my actions signal to
the opponent about
my private information?
I have to think about what do
my opponent's actions signal
to me about their
private information?
It is balancing act.
>> The history of
the evidential stream as well.
>> Exactly. Well, absolutely.
You have to think about
the history of the actions
because that's where
the beliefs get updated from.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you would think about
this as a generalization
of [inaudible] piece
brought into the game setting.
So, it's much more difficult
because you have to think about
those beliefs and then you
need to go to game
theoretic reasoning.
So, it's actually interesting
that there how you should update
the beliefs falls out of
the classic game
theory solution concepts
like Nash equilibrium
and it's refinements.
But the works really
about how do you marry
those concepts with
algorithms from AI,
so we can actually compute
good approximations of
a Nash equilibrium
and it's refinements.
>> Okay, so people
have been trying to
solve this problem for decades.
What was the magic or
the unique innovations that
your team came up with?
I guess I have to say it was
an one cycle you've been
doing this for a while now-
>> That's right
>> -and you finally
got the win. But what
were some of
the findings in results.
>> Okay, so there
have been a lot.
So, I've been working on Poker
as one of the
benchmarks since 2004.
So, from 2004 to 2017, 13 years.
So, it wasn't like one night
we came up with something
and it was done.
It was just like
accumulation of ideas.
>> I can see this is
the same time span.
We have Thomas thinking about
kidney exchanges and then
take a break.Poker
that's kidney exchange.
>> Yeah, that's maybe
that's my style of research
at combinatorial auctions
where you're 10 15 years
kidney exchange for
10 to 15 years and still
is and combinatorial
auctions too.
But it takes a while to really
learn the problem and learn
the techniques at work,
so it's not like one paper
and that's brilliant
and solves the whole thing
it doesn't work like that.
Yeah. So, one is
abstraction techniques.
How do you automatically
abstract the game into
smaller games so that
when you solve the smaller game
perhaps even not
only approximately?
The results are good answers.
The strategies are good
strategies for the original game.
The second is the equilibrium
finding algorithms.
So how do you actually take
a game and find exact or
near optimal strategies
for that game in
a computationally efficient way
both for memory and for speed?
There I would say the number
one thing that actually got
us over the finish line at
the very end clearly there
was accumulation of
work up to then.
But the last thing was these
sub game solving techniques.
Safe new sub game solving
techniques that really got
the final jump 63 milibig plans
per game jump over.
>> Will say more about that,
what [inaudible] sub game plan?
>> So normally if you-
>> What do you do you mean
by sub game plan, also?
>> So, if you normally think
about perfect information games,
you can think about let's
say talk about chess.
So, you get to a state
and then you start thinking
about what do you do from there.
You think from
there to the end of
the game or to some virtual end
of the game if you will.
This is easy relatively
speaking in perfect
information games
because you can solve
the game theoretic solution for
sub game based on information
only in that sub game.
In imperfect information
games you can't,
because you have to think
about the balance of
strategies across
multiple imperfect information
game solve games,
so as to not
give out too much information
for your opponent,
and what these sub game
solving techniques
do is that they
take this idea of
sub game solving into
imperfect information
games which is
very different than in
perfect information games,
and the techniques actually
look totally different.
But still we can find
provably optimal sub game
solving techniques,
so we don't have to look
at the whole game at once,
and therefore, in sub games,
we can actually solve
much finer grain
abstractions come up with
much better strategies
than you can afford to
computationally do if you try
to solve the whole game
monolithically.
>> Let me ask you something,
you see how hard it was
to solve some of
these problems and to get to
the level of that could be
a human or set of top notch
humans in this space.
How on earth did you do
such a good job in this?
>> That is so amazing.
That's a great question.
So, these humans they just
are- I can't even describe it.
They are so good at
this game which is so hard,
and they can talk about
these detailed things some
of them don't even
have college degrees.
Many of them actually do, and
some other computer science,
and economics and so on.
>> Probably inversely
correlated with their skills.
>> But they can talk about
this concept that they've
really learned in
this game specific
way which is very interesting,
and they also have
amazing memories about the game.
So, one guy was
one of these players would
just finish the match.
Played 30,000 hands personally
against this AI, and-
>> Tell me again.
How many of them?
>> Thirty thousand
hands of poker.
>> Against.
>> Against the Hibraro.
So, overall the four players
played 120,000 hands,
so we get statistical
significance,
and to give the human
the best chance
to find holes in the AI.
So, you want to play
a lot of hands.
How long did that take?
>> Twenty days, so 80 days total
of work done in 20 days.
Yeah, so he was asked,
can you come up with
an example where
the AI exhibit this type of
behavior and he would recall
that hand out of
30,000 just like that.
>> That's amazing. So, I
mean I'm amazed that
even a intellect can do this.
Sitting here being burst
situated in this situation.
Understanding each other's
language abilities or
you take a constrained games
as complexity like that.
This human beings
become specialists
to this they have memory that
indexes into what happened.
>> Yeah.
>> Strategy. It
really is impressive.
>> Very impressive.
On the other hand, they
do nothing but
these all day long.
So, they do become specialists.
>> What special
speaking of that topic?
What about, and I'm
sure that the goal was
not necessary to beat
the best players at poker,
it was about to understand
the intelligence better.
So, what have you
learned about AI in
the process of working
with [inaudible] and where
it went per
generalizable principles
and other kinds of
problems you might
solve in the world,
in the open world?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
So, one is that
these techniques are not
techniques for poker.
Therefore, imperfect information
games in general.
As I think about it,
most real world situations
are imperfect information games,
even if they're not
treated as games today.
>> Give me an example
to make a clear.
>> Pricing. So, typically,
when the companies when
they optimize pricing,
they treat it as
an optimization problem,
assuming the competitive
prices are fixed.
Then, when the competitors change
prices, then you re-optimize.
You're always in a reactive mode
behind the eight ball.
While if you think about
these pricing moves ahead,
you can actually do what
I call strategic pricing.
This thing happens in a lot
of industries: finance,
investment banking, sports,
video games, and so on.
So, this has a lot of
applications and I'm actually so
excited at that have found
two companies to fill this.
One is called strategic machine,
and then for government
application, strategy robots.
Were taking these
techniques that we've
developed in the lab
over 16 years now,
and yeah, filling them into
a bunch of things. So, one.
I think you do need to think
about imperfect information,
you do need to deal with
opponents trying to deceive you,
and so on. So, that's one.
The other is there's a lot of
talk about oversight of AI.
We got into this point and
I don't think it's just us,
I think it's a community as well.
Whenever human players,
top players even,
would say, "No,
that's a mistake."
I would actually know
the chances are that the human
is wrong, not the AI.
So, your human oversight
question really became-
>> Which applications is that?
>> Poker. I'm
talking about poker.
So, even the best
poker players when
they would say, "Okay.
That was a mistake."
>> Oh, you mean a poor move?
>> Poor move.
>> Yeah.
>> Or a poor strategy.
Sometimes, you can't think
about the moves in isolation,
you have to think about
whole stretches and moves.
>> Even with the Alpha ghost
story, we saw examples.
That's a poor move and
that turned out to
be unique and interesting.
>> Yes.
>> You move.
>> So, sometimes,
these superhuman moves
or strategies are not
really easily
evaluable by humans.
So, when you say that's
a mistake, maybe not.
I think that's
something as we want to
get humans to be augmented by AI,
we need to think about how
do we deal with the fact
that humans can't really provide
proper oversight for AI,
and AI may also have
its own weaknesses in
providing oversight to humans.
So, there should be
this mutual oversight.
But how do you do
that really when
the humans can't evaluate
superhuman moves?
>> So, where are you?
You're taking on
directions there.
Feel free to speculate
in real time
if you haven't solved
the problem yet.
>> Okay. Well, I
actually don't really think
that humans can provide
very good oversight for
AI in the long run,
because they don't
understand superhuman moves.
So, that's one, and other
is that for a while,
as you get superhuman moves,
you can give humans
extra data around
that decision and give them
time to understand them
and evaluate them,
and try to understand
why wasn't it good,
why was it bad, and so on.
We actually did
this. Chris Ferguson
was looking at our moves
sometimes offline where
something looked like
a really bad move to me
or to one of
the top poker players.
So, we would actually isolate it.
Okay. At that point,
here where the belief
distributions of the AI,
here's the belief
distributions that they
would've had if it were
in the human shoes,
and from these belief
distributions,
was that a good play?
With three days of analysis and
oftentimes a little essay
to go with it,
Chris was able say,
it actually looked
like a dumb move,
but it actually is
like thinking two
levels deeper than
humans ever do,
and it's actually
a brilliant move.
So, with some hindsight and
time and extra context,
humans actually are able to
appreciate and evaluate
superhuman moves.
But I think that'll go away,
that'll only go for a while when
the superhuman moves
aren't too superhuman yet.
But once you get beyond
a certain point,
I don't think so.
>> In the open world,
we have to assume that
some moves advertised as
superhuman might be erroneous,
might be actually wrong.
>> That's right.
>> So, people get used
to accepting moves they
don't understand,
the opacity there.
It's unclear what
the policy should be about
humans actually providing
some oversight.
>> Yes.
>> Be able to stop things or
sometimes, we'll modify them.
>> Yeah. There's also,
if you think about things like
robots where you have to do in
real time in order to take
over the controls or don't you,
and the AI might
have driven you into
a situation where it can still
recover but a human can't.
>> Because a human doesn't
go into those states
base parts and so on. So, it's
a very complicated thing.
>> So, once we have validation
and some notion of trust,
it might turn out that we
have to give robotic systems,
automated systems,
the ability to download.
So, they're doing things that are
understandable to human beings.
So, they can be understood
and guided if necessary.
>> Yeah.
>> Which might be a gentle trade
between two optimality
and winning a game for
example and just
doing a great job.
>> Yeah. I do think, yeah,
this bias, in some applications
might be a gentle trade.
Like, hey you're going to take
over the wheel in the car?
Yeah, that's probably
a gentle trade.
So, but in other applications,
I think the tradeoff
won't be that gentle.
We may have to give up in
some applications,
human understandbility.
>> Certainly, you might
not win a poker game.
>> Yeah.
>> If you give up these moves.
>> Interesting. So, tell
me a little bit
about strategy robot
and why this interest in
helping governments
with their projects.
>> Well, actually, I
started it with
a strategic machine first,
which was really for everything,
and then it turned out that
the potential customer base
is a totally different
and other requirements
are different.
So, I actually had
to split it in two.
One for the commercial
side strategic machine,
and then one for
the government things
which is strategy robot.
>> Tell me more about
the government work.
What problems are
you solving there?
>> So far, we are targeting
things like military planning,
cyber security
applications, intelligence,
war gaming, training,
things like that.
>> Very interesting.
The whole area of AI,
you've been in for
many years and it's
fabulous and it's both
involved in this wonderful
long-term mission
to understand intelligence.
There are different perspectives,
different approaches,
different methodologies,
but certainly a big difference
in point of perspective,
is that people who work
on central algorithms
and deeply coordinated
approaches and the people
that often rely on the power
of distribution methods,
theorems, equilibria, seeking
intelligence in a system
as the sum of many parts
that have been interacting
in certain properties.
I'm curious where you are
these days in your thinking
about the foundations
of human intelligence,
the importance of
central coordination
versus distributed processing.
>> Okay. That's a big question.
>> I hardly ask little questions,
Well, I guess I did
a couple a few minutes ago.
This is a big one, yes.
>> Okay. So, I started
out by thinking at
part of the reason
for distribution
is autonomy and part of it
is computational efficiency,
and those are the distribution
is the same for that tool.
In the track on a system
that's an example where
we did distributed negotiation
peer to peer,
totally distributed.
But then when I moved to
combinatorial auctions around 97,
it became clear that
you can actually get
better allocations
and more efficiently
by having a centralized
clearing point,
like an auction server,
combinatorial auction server with
centralized optimization
algorithms to end allocation.
So, then, there was
this autonomy notion of
different bidders but it wasn't
from a computational perspective.
From a computational perspective,
it was actually
better to centralize.
Now, if you think
about how that works,
for example, we built
our own hosting services,
we were a Software as
a Service company,
one of the first analytics
software and services companies,
but today it would be cloud,
and is at optimized markets,
which is a combinatorial market
company that I'm running.
Their autonomy
based distribution,
self-interest based distribution,
is totally different
than the computational
distribution.
In that from the
player's perspective,
it's a centralized marketplace
while from a computational
perspective,
the clearing engine or
the marketplace
driving optimization,
that is distributed in the cloud
across multiple servers
but those are all in
the centralized clearing point.
So, the distribution for autonomy
and the distribution of
computational speed,
they're totally different.
They're both in
the same market at
the same time but
they're different.
>> So, there's no summering
answer or do you think
that you have to
have that intellect on
both kinds of processes,
coordination might always be
necessary at some level,
more centralized?
>> I won't to say it's
always necessary but
especially when it comes to
these combinatorial problems,
getting good solutions, of
let's say optimal solutions
or near optimal solutions in
these combinatorial
allocation problems.
It is very hard to
do in a peer to
peer way without
a centralized clearing point.
So, maybe just my experience,
tracking being the least sexy but
most combinatorial problem ever,
that's maybe driving
my thinking off that.
But just the way we saw the
more combinatorics there are,
the more benefit there is to
a centralized clearing point.
>> You know your
experience Thomas,
I don't usually ask
this question to folks
but I thought I'll get you
to speculate in real time.
What do you think it's
going on in the human mind?
What what's your
favorite- so give me
your intuitions about
what might be going on
that performs all this magic?
>> I made a commitment
fairly early on
not to worry about it too much.
>> I didn't say worry, I
said what's your best bet,
you must have some guesses and
some inspiration,
some thoughts insights.
Even if we know they're
just guesses right now.
Because sometimes these guesses
guide our research,
even though we don't talk
about this very much.
>> Maybe less so. Actually, when
I was picking a research
topic in the 80s,
one of the other areas I
was very interested in
I had done some things was
deep learning and I guess-.
>> The connection is that in
those days as we called it.
>> Yes. Neural networks.
I was very interested in that,
and just by half fate,
this is more than the game
theoretically strand is
more kind of where I went,
and for better or worse,
it's been an interesting ride.
But I don't know so
much about what's going
in the human mind.
>>But it sounds like
that was an early
curiosity of yours?
>> Yes. Very much.
>> Maybe even powered up
the whole AI direction?
>> Yes. Very much.
>> So, I'll keep it
that right now and we
won't speculate
especially on video.
>> Okay.
>> Turning to other people,
you've been a great mentor to
many students over the years,
and you've had
a very successful career
and much more to come.
What are some words of wisdom
you would like to share
with young folks about career,
more generally even inside
or outside of computer science?
>> Okay. Interesting.
>> I know you probably will
never in video or anywhere
else be asked those two different
questions side by side.
Brain works and your thoughts
are there and then-
>> In computer science,
my advice would be
make sure you have
some real world problem
that you work on
because it will fuel a lot of
interesting research questions
into the research agenda.
It's very hard to come up
with those questions that are
significant if you're just
sitting in your office
with your feet on table or trying
to flip through proceedings.
So, it's better to be
the person who publishes
the first article on some topic,
and brings a new question
into the field rather
than being the guy
who flips through
the proceedings looking for
potential improvements.
That's my opinion. We've
done some of the latter too,
but I think that's
been less impactful.
I think interdisciplinary,
so I foundthat as being
great to be able to
draw knowledge from
multiple different fields.
So, one example is
the game theory
and optimization intersection,
and other is really
the intersection between
AI techniques and
integer programming techniques.
These fields didn't really
talk to each other much,
and this was
tremendously helpful.
Now, they talk to
each other much more
but it was really great to
actually know the techniques
from both sides and
being able to contribute
to that intersection with
both types of toolsets in hand.
So, just reading on both sides,
reading broadly and not
drawing boundaries.
Instead of thinking about it in
a paper I sometimes see people
write to computer
scientists think this,
economists think that
or things like that,
I would never mention a field
of science in a paper,
and I encourage that
nobody else does either
because that erects
boundaries between fields,
instead of taking them down.
It doesn't really matter
whether it was an economist or
computer scientist or an OR
person who said this or that.
That's really irrelevant,
and a waste of space in a paper.
>> Fabulous. Well.
Thanks very much.
It's been great talking to you.
>> Thank you.